bogel doctor doctor doctor doctor never
this I don't care how behind I am on my
videos when Mortal Kombat happens I
talk about that Mortal Kombat
happens I'm going to talk about that
so we got an announcement trailer
today for Mortal Kombat 10 or X it's
Mortal Kombat X officially and at first
I was like holy I'm jacked and then
I was like is that free rendered or is
it in-game graphics first of all it's
cool than a new Mortal Kombat's coming
out we knew a new Mortal Kombat was
coming because edy Boone was teasing us
in Twitter we were like oh and Boone you
tease haha III is right around the
corner some shits going down I shall
scorpion sub-zero fighting that's always
cool it's very iconic and they're doing
all their moves you're like this looks
awesome there's just rap song happening
in the background and you're like
they're doing all the moves and that
looks awesome and the trailer does
confirm certain mechanics that are
coming into this game x-ray moves are
back and I was wondering what parts of
the injustice fight mechanic they're
going to have in the new Mortal Kombat
and I guess you can interact with
objects you see sub-zero breaking off a
branch and beat and scorpion over the
face within your like I guess you can
grab that's all fine and good but
again we come to the part where we're
like is that in-game graphics or is it
pre-rendered CGI nonsense pre-rendered
CGI really it doesn't tell us anything
at all if it's pre-rendered it really
tells us a couple things which is a new
Mortal Kombat's coming out in oh
and it'll have sub-zero and scorpion no
in which case I would have to
wonder with III right around the corner
where we will probably see in-game
graphics why would they make a
pre-rendered trailer why not just hold
off and show us the in-game a week
later remember the Mortal Kombat 9
trailer started out as rendered it shows
Shao Kahn and writing and then Raiden
yells and they clash fists and then it
was just a bunch of in-game graphics
that's what made that trailer awesome
seeing the fast-paced fight mechanic you
know seeing all the moves the combos the
juggles you're like this game looks so
oh my god Mortal Kombat is back with a
vengeance I was hyped for the next year
this in-game graphics that's what people
want to see so it was good willing it I
was like is it pre-rendered or is it
in-game graphics and no one has
confirmed it in fact that neither
NetherRealm Studios or WB games has said
that it's in-game graphics it tells me
he's pre-rendered because I it looks
really good if it's in game graphics and
you'd want to say that you'd be
like yeah that's in game graphics got
awesome we are no confirmation makes me
skeptical of that however there's a
part in this trailer where I was like if
you back up and you vision the life bars
it looks like it's in game graphics if
you look at it people are like it looks
like clunky CGI I'm like that or it
looks like a fighting
happening the clunkiness just looks like
a video game being played it just has
cinematic camera angles at that point
I'm like maybe it is in-game graphic if
you look at this scene right here this
is the same take this scene put life
bars on it looks like in-game graphics
to me whether or not it is I don't know
I can see them doing a thing where the
like it's in-game graphics but we're not
going to tell anybody and on e3 we're
gonna be like oh by the way that
announcement trailer that you were all
pissed at because you thought it was
pre-rendered yeah that's in-game
graphics oh there will all be like oh
we're dicks cuz we doubted them that's
so bad as we're still figuring out this
current ps4 next-gen system we
don't know how good it can look so it's
possible so at the time I'm making this
video there's no real confirmation as to
whether or not this new Mortal Kombat X
trailer is in-game graphics or
pre-rendered the main thing that makes
me think is pre-rendered honestly is the
end fatality scorpion throws the spear
shoots it through sub-zero's head and
then he pulls it back and it hits a tree
and I was like I don't think that's real
simply because there's not going to be a
tree in every loved now if the
fatalities real and he pins his head to
something different in every stage
that's actually really impressive new
Mortal Kombat's happening we're all
pumped for it that's awesome but let's
show the in-game I want to see how
this game plays let's bring so Mortal
Kombat X have you seen the trailer what
do you think about whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]